hi I'm Devin Eric Kapadia a marriage of
calculus and algebra florrum and at
10:30 a.m. this morning I speak with
Adams response key a senior developer on
what's new in calculus or algebra it
should be very exciting to come there
so this is talk what's new in calculus
and algebra
I'm Adam strabinsky it's joined up with
Devendra Kapadia he will finish the talk
so let me start with what's new in
algebra first so the root objects we
have changed the display format of root
objects so if you evaluate a root object
now you will get something like this
short form that just shows the
approximate value it's in an exact
number and there is nothing has changed
in in the underlying expression it's
just a display form that's shorter and
more readable so and another change
related to root objects is that the new
default setting for cubic and quartic
option in solve is automatic which means
that if all the coefficients are numeric
so the roots are numbers then there are
returned as root objects rather than as
radicals we will not use cardinal
formulas to solve third and
fourth-degree equation with numeric
coefficients are unless you asked for it
so that's what we get from solving a
quartic right now and to get the
radicals that Mathematica used to
produce we have to set cortex explicitly
to true and we get the solution in
radicals so let me give you some
motivation for the change so my claim is
that root object representation is much
more useful for further computation
that's that's why we we switched so
first let's try the numeric
approximation the difference here will
not be that large but as it's still
slightly faster to to compute with root
objects however if we do some more
complicated computation like inverse a
matrix with entries that are
root objects or radicals then with root
objects is half a second with radicals I
will not evaluate it it took 18 seconds
so the difference is quite large and if
we make the matrix larger it will grow
so that's about root objects now another
change so in equation inequality solvers
we can now do structure recognition so
that there are a few improvements in
equation in a poetess solver so
structure recognition vector and matrix
inequalities and result projection which
I will shortly say so structure
cognition we can so we can recognize
triangular polynomial systems with
finally many solutions and due directly
into solving for for for the solutions
rather than try to compute to prove
algebraically the d'oeuvre actually
finally many solutions it may happen
that if you have n equations with n
variables the number of solution is
still infinite but it's a rare case so
it's more efficient to try to to find
the finite number of solutions and
detect that but it's not the case we
have infinite solutions rather than
compute governor basis for everything
then the Grabner base dominates the
computation time so here's a few
examples of not evaluate them just show
them so so we have random polynomials of
degree random homogeneous polynomials of
degree 7 and we create a triangular
system so we have one point and one
variable one point two variables and so
on so here we go up to five variables
and we can get all the solutions all the
real solutions now in half a second took
two hundred eighty nine seconds if if we
started with computing Grovner basis and
here's another example which we are
looking
complex solutions so here we find all
the complex solution satisfying the
additional norm condition so we can have
arbitrary triangular system and and an
arbitrary condition for basically we
generate the solutions and check whether
they satisfy the condition so it's it's
an easy solving method but here we can
now find all the 1,400 solutions in five
seconds and mathematical event we didn't
finish in sixty eight hours for this
because of the the Grabner based
computation block triangular system so
again this is this is the the case where
the problem splits into into a number of
independent problems in this joint
subsets of variables so again here here
here's an example with so we take and
two n equations in two n variables and
basically they're they're just
combination of pairs of equations in two
variables so if we take ten equations
with ten variables we can now get all
the median solution in 40 seconds took
two thousand seconds in not greater than
3 and here is something so if if the
number of solutions if is too large we
can easily detect that we have a system
with like here it's 2 to 2 to the nth
solution so if we make an equal thousand
we will not be able to enumerate the
solution so in this case instead of just
hanging or running out of memory we give
a message in return one solution so we
can get one solution in three seconds
and this is the the to two 1000s of
solutions
so the next new things vector and matrix
inequality so this has been introduced
mainly for numerical optimization but
but it's also supported in in symbolic
solvers so we can use vector
inequalities and matrix inequalities so
this for instance says that the matrix
is positive definite and we got solution
so this here here's something which
contains a vector component wise vector
inequality we can solve it we get the
solution Y is a vector so it's Y we get
a pair here right and we solve for at
the general condition for positive
definite matrices and we get the result
in terms of for symmetric mate matrices
yeah well that's the part the part of
the condition is that it's symmetric and
positive-definite so the that's encoded
already in in in this symbol here we
find a depth 3 array such that the first
first element of minus second element is
positive definite and it's an array of
positive integers again we we have now
this new domains where we we can say
positive integers positive reals was
depression also and just just for
convenience and we can also optimize
with such condition so we me my's
Frobenius norm of our matrix with
determinant 1 which is positive definite
and has real entries and we get the
minimum is square root of 2 and here's
the matrix its identity matrix for which
the minimum is satisfied and Lazard
projection it's it's slightly technical
so
basically it's an improvement in it
called algebraic the composition
algorithm which makes it much faster for
for certain inputs it has been a
long-standing conjecture that is then
this projection is is correct it has
been recently proven and we have others
and we can solve this problem in 14
seconds instead of okay so the last
topic it's somewhere on the boundary
between algebra and calculus so
asymptotic solve so if we have a binary
equation then we can solve for one
variable as a function of the other
variable right so if we use solve we get
algebraic solutions that are global but
they are they don't really tell us how
those solutions behave near any given
point so if we are interested how to how
those solutions behave near zero for
instance we can use serious on one of
those root objects but unfortunately
there is no one to one correspondence
between root objects or root functions
and and serious so those functions have
to have unknown branch cut structure
pretty much so so we if we if we use
asymptotic solve we can now get serious
solutions around around the point x
equals 0 here we go we got one one power
series for for we saw serious and have
the advantage of asymptotic solving is
that we can handle much wider collection
of inputs for instance here here we we
can start with something which which is
pretty much arbitrary analytic function
and we get a serious solution near zero
we can plop the result see we used the
solution to as a starting point for
finding roots so we can get sort of
exact solution of the equation and we
can see that there are synthetic
solution to the exact solutions are
pretty close near zero they start of
diverging further away but it's those
and there will be more about asymptotic
solve in the next talk and now I'm going
to get flow Devendra Thank You Adam
I'm going to talk about calculus and I'm
going to begin with pretty high level
stuff asymptotics and special functions
and then move down a little bit to what
our average user college user would use
in telling differential equations and
then finally talk about people who don't
even use Mathematica yet high schoolers
and people only learn calculus so we
start out high and then descend but my
main point is that a lot of this work is
joint work with the team most of it is
not mine and I'll try angle credit but
really it's a team effort well beyond
our own team stretching to the training
teams so didn't begin with asymptotic
calculus so in version 11.3 we
introduced asymptotic dissolve value or
asymptotic integrate for finding
approximations to differential equations
and integrals and in version 12 we are
now going to the discrete world of
sequences and we have two new functions
asymptotic are solve value for
difference equations and asymptotic sum
for indefinite indefinite sums so given
a sum or a difference equation we now
try and get you an asymptotic a simple
formula that encodes everything you
might want to know about the sequence so
as an example of this he does in a case
we have given a sequence that's a
sequence so here it's some god-given
sequence for now okay and I say someone
says find me an approximation for the
300th term of the sequence right so in
version 7
Charles did a very nice job of putting
up something called fine sequence
function which will try and case a
formula well in this case what happens
is find sequence function doesn't quite
succeed it goes back a different route
so good like a difference equation and
of course you can work with that but now
what we can do is we can take this thing
over here and feed it to our new solver
which is asymptotic our solve value and
I make sure to put a decimal point in
one of the initial conditions and then
lo and behold it gives back an
approximate formula and that approximate
formula it's pretty good but I said it's
a god-given sequence it's not quite that
I chose very carefully actually so this
sequence over there really is the sum of
the squares of the factorials so if you
look at 42 and 6 1 8 and then 42 plus
576 two six one eight but then 576 is 24
square and 24 is four factorial so
that's a very simple sequence really so
I can also use a new function called
asymptotic sum which will do the same
thing for you and give you back
exactly the same approximate formula now
question is all that is good but how
good is the approximation well let's try
it so here's the three had term with our
approximation that nice simple formula
and here's the exact result from some
itself and you can see the approximation
is pretty good given how little effort
we took to obtain it so that's the new
theme given a sequence find the thousand
term we can do it for you now in a flash
okay so on to special functions
that's a heavy topic but what happened
is that we have documentation now which
includes around 2000 scope examples from
400 functions in in the system and it's
all borrow from functions website etc
and now what we do is we can find polar
plots and all kind of stuff on the pages
which couldn't be seen early on they
look quite beautiful we did 100 of them
150 to go will finish soon within a
month or two so when version 12 ships
will have 250 brand new pages for
special functions and let's say you want
to learn about hyper to marry to f1
that's an important special function so
now what I do is I go there and let me
enlarge a little bit so we can all see
nicely and now if I go down to the scope
section that's a mini functions website
it's got everything you want to know
about special functions in this case
hyperactive f1 so you might want to say
okay what does the graph look like will
you have got a nice set of graphs over
here and that happens for every single
function in the system that's really
quite a big change
okay now hypergeometric is one level of
special functions but you need to go
beyond that
so the new generation of special
functions are what are called Hein
functions and these hunt functions
believe it or not they are more general
than hyper geometric so hyper great
functions are a very special case of
point functions and you see in this
sentence over here in one sense is a
blown-out hypergeometric have said ong
of something is happening to f1 hyper
geometric is all absorbed into Hein and
why they more general
well the hyperkinetic differential
equation has got three singular points 0
1 and infinity and coin has got four of
them there's one more here and that
makes life quite difficult for everyone
ok so years as no diesel value telling
you that you have one kind of regular
solution at zero and then one kind of
singular solution now if you've got four
single era T's you can start merging
them in confluences so there are five
coin functions confluence ones and then
you've got five derivatives so there are
10 new Hein functions and you might
wonder why do you need them I mean why
bother kind of bit well DeGraw know
here's a real expert on these Hein
functions and he's published at 11
people on this one of them deals with
two-state corn systems so as we go
forward in quantum computing a black
hole here etc we will need hein
functions and they'll be there for you
this is the
this is the future for special functions
hypergeometric is out coin is in okay
okay so let's go on a little lower now
two differential equations over here we
have these four now gives back very nice
constants which it I did and nice thing
is you can still plot them just like
before and nothing has changed but you
get nicely formatted subscript that
makes my own work very simple when I
look at solution it looks nice now the
c1 and c2 look just right okay
the other thing is that on Stack
Exchange was nicely discussion about
nonlinear ode ease so I got inspired to
solve a twenty-year-old problem namely
how do you solve initial value problems
for first order nonlinear ode ease
you're the heart example and now it
comes back in a flash of the correct
solution but then I asked reduce how
good is my solution it said oh it only
goes up to 1 over square root of 2 so I
said okay let me take it over there and
now what I do is I give that old
starting point as a new starting point
or the old finishing point a new
starting point over here and I get back
in equalization so you got a nonlinear
OD which is got two solutions one which
is kind of curve one it's flat and
together they make up the complete
solution so the the the solution which
is equilibrium coming from left and just
takes the old solution with it all the
way up to infinity that's pretty
dramatic for me I have not seen it
before and one last thing is that for a
long time we have kind of had to cope
with very hard integrals which TESOL
cannot do so now we return in active
integrals so over here you have a fourth
order OD I'm building up from Bessel
equation using differential operators I
get back the fourth order OD I solve it
and D solve using factorization it comes
back in probably a couple of second with
all the work done there are Intel's over
there but they all inactive and I can
finally check the solution over here and
I get back a zero
almost immediately they okay so now the
point is that this is a very important
thing first because there is some
example if you take one are in 11.3 and
now this inner shop in 0.1 second that's
almost as good as a compiler next door
so I think we are really doing well away
yeah okay so on to symbolic integration
so we now can give constant integration
that's you know Michael trout you asked
me to implement this I did so you get
back console integration and you can do
pretty difficult things that's ok right
so let me just take a minute more and
simplify over here and you get back the
result we can do some pretty difficult
integrals such as this one over here
from Ruby and we can do this one from
our own test suite quite nicely the
documentation is looking real nice with
eta is hard work and we should have a
new rest paid for integrate in version
12 and my last point for just a minute
is going to be that we went from high
level to college and from Colleyville go
to high school and we now have a new
interactive calculus course I did 50
videos over the last six months in this
very Wolfram building and thanks to work
by training group we now have a complete
interactive calculus course with quizzes
and whatever you like it's available to
everyone free of charge you're welcome
to try it out recommend to other people
but that's a big leap for us so finally
where are we headed in future well we
want to go into linear algebra and talk
about a course for linear algebra we
finished solving one book we won't do
more and we have a workshop this off
known which we'll discuss that in more
detail but basically my point is that
calculus and algebra in are in very good
shape we've got plenty of stuff in
version 12 we'll have much more coming
up later on for precalculus college
calculus
algebra advanced etc we're going to keep
going so thank you very much
[Applause]